does the president's party usually gain
or lose seats at the midterm elections
it's a pretty strong historical trend
that the president's party loses seats
in the presidency so that's particularly
the case in the House of Representatives
since the Civil War about 93 percent of
the time the president's party loses
seats now sometimes they lose a lot of
seats and the entire control of the
house switches from controlling the
president's party to control into the
other party in the Senate it's a little
less direct about 70 percent of the time
the president's party loses seats in and
awe in a midterm election and this is
often seen and more in more recent
history it's really seen as and kind of
thumbs-up or thumbs-down vote on how the
president is doing the electorate
reacting to whether they like or dislike
what the president is doing and in the
two cases recently where the president's
party did pick up seats in in congress
it was in 1998 when the Republicans were
seen to have overreached in their
impeachment of Bill Clinton and so
voters voted for Democrats Bill
Clinton's party and then in 2002 when
George W Bush was seen as successfully
responding to the 2001 attacks on the
World Trade Center in the Pentagon and
and America his party picked up seats in
the congressional election because it
was seen as a as a ratification of his
presidency so far